set a timer for 30 minutes to order food
no maybe 20 minutes changed my mind
Siri I changed my mind 20 minutes all
right you ready are we doing hey guys
it's Justine I'm Jenna
welcome to same brain podcast episode 5
episode 5 hey do you remember in the
last episode when we said we were going
to read some more reviews I absolutely
do Justine and I have them pulled up
right in front of my phone in my face
alright let's let's read one and I'm
gonna find some audio snippets here
because you could also leave us audio
messages on anchor I know I did it was
incredible I made an account
alright so right now we have amazing
sound quality oh my gosh thank you when
I heard about you guys making podcast
now I decided to just listen to it for a
bit and then all of a sudden I didn't
notice I was already 33 minutes in now I
kind of like podcasts I mainly like your
podcasts thank you a very very very the
review we like to read and one just says
finally with a smiley face oh my gosh
Thank You Jacob I loved the WWDC one
your voices are really suing loved it
and would definitely recommend my thank
you will Hobbes fan six amazing cast and
Jenna absolutely wild
that was from Alan thank you and let's
see we have one from Trey vlogs trey is
always in the chat always being
supported okay here's our from David
Paris also a big supporter I just tuned
in Jeannette your boot cut is the best
love you I mean how can you deny that
the podcast is when David receives the
official review oh thank you guys for
always leaving the messages as well as
the reviews Maddie right now is leaving
a he's leaving a review on anchor he's
leaving his audio message because he
can't type with his birthday
shortened to the point it's sweet we
love that
yeah I just love your podcast alejandro
has a podcast all about Animal Crossing
how sweet so this isn't a sponsor this
isn't an ad but anchor if you do want to
sponsor our podcast we are here for it
because I absolutely love you guys yeah
this is so easy to use like you can make
a podcast record edit on your phone it's
pretty crazy
this isn't even sponsored I know you
like but I'm willing well we have a bank
account and I really like it really is
it's like it's so user-friendly and this
is also something that this really cool
is anybody can also make money because
they have sponsorships that they will
give you and then you can record the
sponsorship ad on your phone and then
insert it into each episode it's
seriously violence I love it I loved
were on board we were five episodes in
we're gonna really on board alright so
for today's episode we have a lot of
stuff to talk about yeah what should we
start with I was looking for stuff to
chat about this morning first of all
this week was a really exciting week
actually today is also July 4 oh happy
July 4th happy 4th of July
can you believe it we've been
celebrating with fireworks for the past
month it seems like and finally the July
4th weekend they make them illegal my
goodness and I just to clarify we have
not been no he's not like you know
worldwide there's been an outrage of
fireworks but yes fourth of July weekend
- it's crazy though because every night
actually even during the day you just
hear fireworks all the time it's pretty
crazy yeah and I mean every time I would
always go to like the one by me likes a
nice firework show and this year it's
canceled we went into that really cool
hike one day oh yeah like a couple years
ago with our other sister we have
another sister a bri-bri and she has a
baby do you think that we will have the
baby on the podcast one day oh yes
[Music]
when will we be able to travel again
because we just shut down Los Angeles
for another three weeks it's true yeah
they've closed down dine in restaurants
which makes sense I mean if they even
open up dine in restaurants was crazy to
me like I can see maybe doing gyms and
things like that but restaurants like
you have to take your mask off to eat
food right sure I mean even gyms is kind
of touch-and-go cuz like you're
literally sweating and if you're running
you're breathing and I our gym opened
back up and I was like I'm gonna go as
soon as it opens and to investigate so I
went and it was kind of interesting they
gave you a wristband and there was like
two people in there and the entire gym
so was like okay I don't feel as weird
about this but no one had masks on while
running no one had them on while working
out and I was there for 15 minutes I was
like I'm not ready for this yet I'm
gonna leave
what was the wristband for I don't know
did they take your temperature no I was
like we probably should maybe take a
temperature but it was just really
interesting I just I'm just like I don't
really feel comfortable for this yeah
I'll come back another time but I feel
like at least gyms and things like that
if you are wearing masks I know Equinox
has made you wear gloves as well no I
just got a notification I need to cancel
my membership here's the thing about
gloves that potentially could be just
spreading the germs more because if
you're just wearing gloves once throwing
them away that's why you're supposed to
be wearing the reusable gloves people
are wearing them like all day long so
then you're just transmitting it even
more so if you're not careful with the
gloves you're kind of just making it
worse
I think that's also the argument with
masks like people aren't washing their
masks either so they are supposed to be
washed because like that bacteria and
stuff is just kind of festering on it
festering no one likes festering wear
the mask wash it have a couple if you
have disposable ones if you're not able
to wash it wait didn't you say the
twitter just tweeted something man just
we did yes this is when we're shooting
it they tweeted you can have an edit
button when everyone wears a mask yeah
go has almost 400,000 likes it's only
been up for an hour I just don't like
that the masks I've turned into a
political statement when really I mean
for me and I think a lot of my friends
it's just being considerate of other
people around you
we can talk circles around this there's
always gonna be a debate but at the end
of the day you know if you're able just
pry the masks or just stay home there's
so many services especially I mean in
these bigger cities where like you can
have groceries delivered it's also very
convenient true and a lot of times
there's really not a delivery fee for
Amazon I mean I'll sometimes do the rush
fee and I would much rather be able to
leave a higher tip than pay a delivery
fee for something so actually tipping
the person that's bringing it to you so
they can actually get that money sure
yeah I definitely feel better about that
too I'm like okay cool like someone's
out working like I would rather give you
the money give you work and I don't have
to leave the house I mean of course it
does put these people at risk because
they're leaving the house it's really
there's just no good solutions not and
it's so stressful it's very stressful
everything is stressful but let's talk
about something else okay sorry I just
it's everything's crazy I he's crazy
I don't know anyway be kind we'll move
on to some iPhone news week after 13
years of the iPhone being on sale that I
don't know where I'm going with some I'm
not phrasing this properly but the
iPhone has been on sale for 13 years
that's what I was trying to 13 years ago
the iPhone officially went on sale
that's what I was saying God did I say
that but we're just gonna say it 13
years ago the iPhone officially went on
sale where were you I was at the Mall of
America when I was on sale when it went
on sale I did not even have enough money
to buy the iPhone I basically didn't
even have money to pay my rent so a
company had flown me out there to sort
of cover the event because I was
actually live-streaming on justin.tv
back then oh my gosh whole circle people
fools are freaking circle I was live
streaming the line the the launch line
and also I have a video here do you want
to see this video yes this is Joe he was
the first person in line and this is a
video of me watching him open his iPhone
I'm wearing a really weird necklace you
have shorts on I might actually I think
I had like capri pants on years ago I
was 17 oh I was in high school I don't
want to do the math on how old I was but
either way this is something around this
is look at that you can see the little
camera with the hat on it my hat with a
camera on what were you think about it
let's could we just like talk more about
this wonderfully cameras so if someone
who is holding the hat with a camera for
you so you can be in the fan I could be
in the video
Oh who wasn't do you know who it was was
just a random person no it was uh so his
name was Edie and he worked for the
company at the time so this is one the
first times that a company had me come
out to cover an event other than in San
Francisco when I went to the launch of
the iPhone so this was huge now just
think about this a little small Justine
who were her entire life has loved Apple
she got to go to see the iPhone but
didn't get the I couldn't get that
iPhone but but you anything you're like
just excited to be there and I look
that's like that's cool but this is
where it gets even more exciting is like
they knew that I was so in love with
like Apple and everything and I was sort
of trying to figure out what the heck
was happening and all of this and they
sent me that iPhone like they sent me
the phone it was a surprise I had no
idea is this the phone that launched the
bill yeah oh okay now they are taking it
full circle so it's like those small
little things I feel like no one ever
realizes like what an impact is
something that small could have on
somebody's entire career like if I they
would assign me that phone and you maybe
not wouldn't have been here I might not
have been here you would probably still
be in Pittsburgh
I believe I'm actually I was looking at
there's some really nice houses in
Pittsburgh yes yeah yeah I know
anyway it still has to know it does have
snow that's the problem you can get a
lot of land that's true but I don't know
if postmates works sometimes out there
it works in the city of post mates so I
have this all set up so that I can order
food by the time we're done with the
podcast we'll be able to eat the floor
only ten years ends of don't order that
no we got an order yet
so 13 years ago the iPhone went on sale
how much did it cost that's actually a
great question
I know oh my god that doesn't seem like
it's in the document Tyler how much does
the iPhone lost
Tyler is Tyler going so we're also
working on a new podcast set up so that
we can give Tyler mic so he can also
kind of enjoyment lovely fun that we're
doing Tyler is wrapped up in an emoji
blanket right now very chilly forever
999 dollars that's the lowest version
though yeah I'm going to Apple's website
to see what it looked like back then
so that was 2007 January let's he would
do like a nice January ish because that
was whenever the announcement happened
that's January let's take a little look
and see with this January 25th what did
Apple's website look like January 25th
where were you Jenna I think that was
icy I was 17 this is really strange but
I think that was one of my ex-boyfriends
birthday really yeah I don't remember
why I would always forget his birthday
and I'm like okay it's a month after
Christmas don't forget January 24 my
goodness okay wait so January though you
guys January 25th introducing iPhone
Apple reinvents the iPhone and it's
Jenna's boyfriend of ABS video
that's hilarious you get that oh my
goodness this is crazy it's really as it
is impressive how Apple has
revolutionized so many different things
in this industry
it says introducing iPhone Apple
reinvents the phone you remember when I
just said that two seconds ago I'm not
sure if you did I'm not I do do you know
I was I was blushing with I wanted to
read it better look at this look at this
header right here so you guys can't see
it but well unless you're watching the
video we put an overlay of it
this graphic so I remember I so I
watched school for graphic design video
editing all of that stuff so I used to
mimic this design me and every designer
at the time would do like this sort of
glossy little button I love a glossy
button lossy button the gray aw man I
think I made my portfolio when I
graduated high school
College sorry like my design portfolio
basically looked like this the glossy
but it's a very nice classic look man
that's crazy so then how long after the
event did you get the phone so it would
have been let's see I just see an iPhone
bill I think I posted this city was
probably like I mean it wasn't
immediately this was I posted this video
in August oh so that's it was a few
months after that's pretty recent
there's like a year after no but I mean
it's still a few months after wait that
was recently on June July August
a month after so I think they sent it
shortly after because this is the new
phone bill yes that you had your bill if
you guys remember and some of you if you
don't know I got a phone bill that was
over 300 some pages I've talked about
this on I feel like everyone's podcast
in the whole entire world
every single interview but this phone
bill it itemized every single text
message that I sent and received the
itemization mostly all of these things
were texts so back in the day Twitter
used to be text only it's still to this
day shows up if I type in like a two
because it was like whatever the
Twitter's like it would do six five
whatever it was 404 but yeah if I type
in if I start like I've been four it'll
say like Twitter and I'm like oh my gosh
this is how we had to send text messages
back in the day that was 2006 when I
first joined and I made pretty much
everyone I know joined Twitter at a time
so the initial followers that I had were
all of like my really good friends that
I made everyone sign up for so the fact
that all of those tweets or texts worked
worked for tweets when did I join
Twitter it does say on your profile
right I think it does trying to see
probably joined believe shortly after
maybe it was May 2000 it was definitely
May mine was oh oh that's not that's
when I was born okay I joined October
2006 I joined May 2007 oh that was well
after oh my watch was after yeah because
I was in October okay May is not that
long it's not life after it that's so
Emily talk to you back then when did we
become friends probably when I was like
20 yeah nineteen
20 after because I feel like you were in
high school by I was my college well
yeah but I'm saying like the the the
difference of a page
yeah I'd say probably that was like 20 I
remember
Jana used to come out to LA and help I'm
like shoot videos like very early on
yeah I've also didn't have many friends
out here either so I was coming out like
once a month and I'm on college so I
have to like I would usually take off
like a Friday you're like a Monday cuz
if you lose a whole day traveling to Los
Angeles from Pittsburgh so I don't like
a day and then there was never direct
flights no we would have to take like
the crappiest cheapest flight you get
here because you really weren't making
that much money either
no like you were fine but like we're
like how can I get out of your cheap
budget and only stay for two days and
shoot as much content as possible so
that was that was kind of crazy but it's
also hard because Los Angeles is very
expensive and I have always whatever
money I get I end up investing back into
what I'm doing yeah so it's like okay I
need to get a bigger camera I need to
get a better computer I need to keep
upgrading upgrading upgrading so I mean
that's I mean it's great to get the new
gear put a lot of times especially back
then I mean it's very very difficult
it's hard but let's talk about the most
recent rumor with the iPhone Justine
that it will not be coming with a
charging brick so here's the thing this
doesn't affect me at all because I do
wireless charging for almost everything
now the only time I ever need a cord is
when I'm pulling photos off of here to
put them on to like my computer or
something wireless charging is really
really slow yep so that's the only thing
where I'm like at night I'll toss it on
the wireless charger during the day I'll
toss it on toss it on but like if I need
like a fast charge I'll plug it in but
if you're if you have meanhow power
times a week do you plug in your phone
honestly I usually plug it in really I
never I don't think I've plugged my
phone in since this I bought this phone
because the battery life especially on
the iPhone 11 Pro max it's really good
it has been pretty good I mean I would
say at least a couple times like
definitely plug it in just because I'm
like oh my phone's dead I needed to
charge faster wireless charging is fast
or if you like knock it off in the
slightest bit it won't charge have you
ever like you know woke up like man I
didn't charge a few times yes and I'm
also very careful like at night to make
sure that it is on the dock but even
like my Apple watch I charged it I have
like one of those nomads
charging up pads if it has the B Apple
watch charger and the iPhone but I
honestly never use that at all anymore I
do but I mean I get it I get it and how
many like cords do we have that are you
would think right I have a lot but
anytime I actually need one where do
they come what's interesting is what if
they go to the USBC charging are they
not going to give you a cord all I've
ever wanted but hear me out if you're an
iPhone use are going and upgrading from
a previous iPhone they hit you with that
USB C charger and you're like and you
didn't give me a charging cord Oh
suing they would offer you I mean you
buy it as an accessory would they offer
an option to buy it with the cord
without the cord or just just as an
accessory well you know what Jenna let
me push a button I knew you're like
which one does one wall honestly I'm not
really sure will it do cheaper I think I
mean I would imagine it would be I mean
obviously Apple loves to have those
accessories as like a nice little up
charge but if they're I mean they were
also talking about having it there no
ports either so how do you backup your
phone in the cloud it's really slow 5g
that's also a potential option I know
so if we have 5g if we have these fast
speeds that are promised to us then
that's fine but also faster wireless
charging I mean yes that's it's gonna
happen eventually here's the thing not
everyone would have the 5g you know to
mean like think about when we gonna run
parents house how they were in the
middle of nowhere I mean at that point I
can run to Starbucks that's like 15
miles away faster than I can upload a
video it's actually very very true cuz
it takes like 10 hours so it is very
interesting to see like they're gonna
have to have some type of solution where
it's like okay hey maybe you know that
there Promax version they have this one
version that is gonna be for like these
tech people who live in this 5g world
where we can have the 5g and we can have
the wireless charging with no ports and
then another version where our people
who you know like the old-school style
but still want the newer you know the
newer upgrades yeah I mean there's so
many different rumors I mean I'm looking
at Apple
20:20 iPhone lineup can you believe I'm
reading this right here but I'm reading
the words and it's not quite
comprehending we're a few months away
from the launch of the 20/20 iPhones
September October that's like iPhone
season spooky too sexy
Jenna has these labeled this is her
spooky label spooky this is sexy labeled
that chimes ah sorry changing with the
bump so I was trying I was trying to
write but there's like as a BA or pop
how there's drums yeah like oh it's okay
hey I didn't say I was gonna do a good
job I just thought I was gonna get the
job done 2020 iPhones will feature major
updates introducing some of the first
design changes we've seen since the
iPhone 10 which is not that long I own X
how many times I have almost fall out of
my chair
okay 2020 will be the first year the
iPhone introduces 5g support to the
iPhone which makes sense because 5g
isn't everywhere so if you're putting 5g
in a phone that no one would really even
buy because they don't have 5g anywhere
where they are doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense but I mean you know
the future eventually they said 2020 was
the year of 5g who said that they did
whose day they did who's they they did
what who they as in well a lot of these
big companies you like we've got all
we've got Qualcomm we got Samsung I mean
look at Samsung you know how many
devices they have now that r5g like I
think they did not introduce a new phone
without 5g you're right well I mean in
honestly when I was doing a test just in
my apartment and well here's the thing
this wait it was to Jupiter talking I've
got something to show you speaking of
Samsung okay she's stuck behind it up
Wow but when I was doing a test in my
apartment one time I was like I wouldn't
do a speed test
it was Verizon versus I believe t-mobile
no as AT&T and it was the five it was so
fast and it was with like these Samsung
devices you can do 8k and upload
directly
to YouTube in 8k so imagine doing that
with 5g rapid speed people imagine yeah
give me this she come back with a
Samsung box so in the last podcast
episode justine that's me has discovered
BTS can you okay it's so since then
people have sent me videos I've done
some research I'm not ready to talk
fully about any of my favorite songs or
my favorite band members because I'm
still learning well what I have learned
is they are incredibly talented Oh
sometimes they're very catchy they use
collabed with so many incredible artists
to like it's just it's great so I've
also started I just said hey si RI
blamey top BTS songs and I've been
getting a lot of great hits so I'm still
learning and I'm very excited to to show
you this I've always been doing the same
the reason that I was like maybe I
really should check out BTS because
everybody's been telling me that they're
incredible well you guys weren't lying
right now she is showcasing a box she's
opening the box up this is the phone
that we're talking about in the last
episode this is the Samsung S 20 + 5 g
BTS Edition it's beautiful those are the
earbuds I know but I'm looking at them
but it's so cool because the box has
like the purple and pink like little
hearts it's really cool is this the
ultra I have to send this back yeah this
is just like a review unit oh oh my gosh
I'm gonna have any heart yes on the I'm
gonna have to reenact this excitement
for what I actually unbox this on my
channel oh my goodness there is a little
heart on the frontal this is actually
the back yeah this is the back this is
the front but look at this this call
it's like a matte finish it's like a
there's a heart by like the cameras
that is incredible this looks really
good I cannot wait to do an unboxing of
this which I'm going to do here shortly
but look at the color whoa it's like an
iridescent purple we're seeing this on
my nail loose I guess what just 5g
enabled I know
anyway I wanted to do a follow up with
you and just thank everyone for sending
me songs to to listen to music videos to
watch videos which actually I sent you a
couple of learning the band members and
their specialties of what I've loved so
much about them so far is their like
their interaction with each other like
they're always pulling pranks and
they're just really funny like it kind
of reminds me a harmless humor do it
yeah it's like fun oh no I love it
I'm so excited I'm I'm excited to be
becoming a small small fan they make her
into a bigger fan of the BTS army like I
feel like I'm yeah it's very catchy too
cuz I'm well you actually just got it to
that new Belkin speaker I was like
setting it up and it's really cool
because it's integrated with Google and
you connected to your how you Spotify so
I connect it to my Spotify so I'm just
like hey goog Ellie play you know top it
so BTS and then I'm just like popping my
head around the house and it's a it's
pretty it's pretty cool a fan know I'm
very excited to further my research it's
like you know wake up in the morning do
a little research on BTS I love this no
I'm super excited search every day a
little bit I'm learning slowly so what
else do we have in the news just you you
have so much at the time I also saw that
the Apple we now have an Apple portal
for the card the credit card which I
didn't realize wasn't a thing actually
announced it forgot to pay me so Justine
let me tell you about this weekend I
called it's called Auto pay I think I
did if you select Auto pay at the end of
the month or whenever it will take the
money from your account okay okay
nevermind I paid it I paid it cuz I got
him in case you hear about auto pay auto
pay generals talking about auto pay it's
a really new heater fascinating new
feature just introduced probably fifty
years ago
so whatever the internet came out what
is what's so special about the portal
cuz I did not see this well you can now
access it from a web browser so
basically like you would normal bank
statements you know how like sneaky and
secretive like the Apple I can't even
find my apple cart at the time like the
digital version I'm like where is it
so it's in the wallet you go into the
wallet but then like I don't know it's
just always confusing but now that you
can just go to card
and you can pull up your statement and
just makes it a little bit more user
friendly of an experience especially for
people that if they do have this at what
I mean for me like I've been using it
for business expenses so I have to send
that stuff to my accountant so he's
always like hey can you send me that
Apple card statement oh my gosh how do I
do it you can download the PDF through
the app in the wallet but it's like this
is way easier a lot easier basically I
use my Apple card at Whole Foods because
it's Apple pay and that's where I walk
I'm like on a walk and I end up at Whole
Foods all the time and my twitch my
twitch money connected to that so only
like how do I spend thousands of dollars
at Whole Foods and on twitch all right
but now I can easily see it on the web
browser well well I mean that's but no
I'm glad they do have that this was also
something this was in the beginning that
I wanted to talk about so Martin Cooper
on April 3rd 1973 made the first cell
phone call oh now you old you I sent you
the link to this but you didn't watch
the video you see you guys I'll have to
put some link in show notes guys can
watch it I got called out you did it's
ok but it's a really good video and he
was just talking about how when he made
the first phone call there was only two
of these phones in existence at this
time so who did he call the other phone
so I watched the video but now I don't
remember who he called little talking
about this this was the world's first
flip phone that cost $1000 in 1996 and
this was a legendary retro phone
Motorola StarTAC rainbow version is
about as vintage as you can get if you
like Eugene a little bit now this person
bought this on eBay so that's what this
article is about so I actually did have
one of the Motorola ones which was our
mom's phone that she gave me and I
didn't get a cell phone until I went to
college when did you get one um I was 15
I went to high school well they were a
little bit more accessible than a smart
phone it was a red flip phone that goes
LG something is like red flip up has a
little keyboard like tip tip tip job
don't think it had internet just basic
and then my first smart phone was a
blackberry I do remember that you got
your blackberry you were so my friends
were like we've got a bbm and I'm like
I want an iPhone but the iPhone wasn't
available on Verizon at the time we had
that Network so I couldn't get an iPhone
so I got the bbm I remember because I
used to be on the Verizon family plan
and then I wanted a smartphone so I got
B sprint a trio it was like a little
palm actually you probably don't get it
yeah but that was my first smartphone
and that was the first time that I left
the family plan but just sprint dun dun
dun then I was like oh my gosh now I
gotta get out of the sprint contract and
then I went to I went to AT&T with the
iPhone it's so crazy how difficult it is
to like get a phone plan I feel like
it's a really difficult process does
seem like a difficult it is expensive
and just they always try to like I feel
like rip you off I don't know like it
has it been like easier it just always
seems like it's such an ordeal it does
and because you have to be contracted in
I think that's why a lot of people do I
mean I'm not sure what it's like in
other countries but I think what
t-mobile has done was sort of their
months when the plans they've done a lot
of really great things to sort of change
that and then also I did this was last
year remember I did a sponsored project
with metro pcs so but it was great
because they also did the month to month
plans this is not sponsored by them now
but I did do this project it was really
fun because we had one of the Wi-Fi cars
sure yeah so it was really great just to
see their prices that they had and they
do have lower end prices but you could
still get you talk to your phones as
well which is really cool yeah that's
good I feel like there's definitely a
lot more options than back then it's
like this is what you can get for this
much money and it's like how much money
or you're locked into a contract for two
years it's crazy and also Apple does a
thing too which was interesting is you
so if you don't buy your phone outright
you can be paying monthly but then if
you go to upgrade the phone then you
have to pay that phone off really to be
able to buy the other phone well I think
they do a leasing program where you can
be eligible every year so you basically
are leasing your phone it's like a car
you're leasing your phone and then you
just the next phone comes out if you
want to upgrade you can upgrade it
probably it might be a little bit more
or might be exactly the same so that's
actually a really really nice program
but you're not gonna own your phone
unless you buy it but you can also have
the new phone this becomes that old
article that I found but I was looking
for just more news on like the
the 13-year iPhone being sold and this
is this is from last year so this is
2019 in December as Apple has a secret
team working on satellites to beam data
to devices so this would kind of
eliminate what you're saying the
contracts that these satellites could
just beam data directly to your phone so
this is I mean I'm sure there's probably
this probably had updates but it says
Amazon also plans to deploy more than
3,000 satellites as part of a future
integration with this type is up I don't
know I mean I'm just thinking about it
the other day this is so like we don't
there's so much that we don't know I
mean it's kind of like the ocean as well
I think you're like in the ocean in
space it's fascinating
speaking of the ocean Justine I know
we're not there yet but we decided to do
a section I decided and she decided I
don't shock me in 2020 like you know
normally things you back well that's
shocking but 2020s been such a crazy
year where I see these headlines I do
these things I'm like not really
surprised anymore I saw a video of a
bird carrying and flying with a shark
plucked the shark from somewhere and is
flying around with it
I think they might have plucked it from
the ocean well it could be like a washed
up it was close to the ocean do you
think that he wow I need more
information
I wish we could get that Hawk on the
podcast how do we get how do we get the
bird what type of bird was it there
sighs it's so much information I have to
give I have so many questions I have so
many oh yeah you don't know any
information I only have the video in it
look I wish I knew more about sharks so
I could see what type it looks like a
baby shower a baby shower listen to it
but it does look like a baby shark what
happen
oh you're not gonna see a bird carrying
a great white shark well I'm 2020 would
you be shocked No
okay shocking thing you've heard this
year okay this is listed under things
that don't shock me but I'm slightly
shocked but now I probably shouldn't be
okay look I don't what I'm just gonna
read the headline Alabama students hold
kovat 19 parties with a prize for the
first person to get sick do you
people are dying when they get this this
is this this illness I'm just not sure
if if you guys are aware it is it's not
even like it's just you know like oh
it's old but it's literally ranging from
like a four month old to like an 85 year
old that people have died what are you
doing you idiot
I'm sorry I'm sorry to name-call but
this is this is really stupid
your entire family can be infected guys
don't get sick or have the symptoms it's
just really silly I mean yeah I remember
being young and dumb but I was never
that dumb I feel like like that this is
really bad I'm very it's very very very
silly thing so if anyone is out there
thinking like wow I want to go to a
party where the first person to get skov
in nineteen gets a prize of money I'm
gonna do it here's the thing do you have
health insurance is your money gonna
cover you know your health care and
going to the emergency room and being on
a ventilator for a month go with no trip
to the emergency room just to be seen
could be on the low end of five thousand
dollars if you don't have a turn that
it's pretty crazy and no this is it just
makes me so sad because we've had
friends who have been personally
affected by this who have had family
members pass away who have been to the
point of them going to sleep at night
and not sure if they're gonna wake up
with them so soon like you know their
family members are dying and like you
can't be with them in the hospital
basically this is article I read it and
I was like I'm not surprised by this but
at the same time I'm shocked that these
people exist in the world I was
surprised and I'm sad very very crazy if
it's something that you have friends
that are doing please that try to
encourage them that this is a very bad
idea because everything that we're doing
like staying in the house and all of
this quarantine this is ruining all of
that that everyone is putting forth a
lot of effort to try to stop her Eddie's
another racquetball it's like okay so we
were quarantined for three months and
that was basically wasted like we
literally have been in the house for
three months for nothing so anyway
justine we have done our we have
lectured ohio it's just so sad I'm so
sad this was a majestic sighting a
pearly white beluga whale was spotted
off Mission Bay in San Diego last week
and what's believed to be the fur
ever sighting of a beluga whale on the
west coast here do you think that maybe
vide buting beluga whale beautiful they
should probably they should just go away
not nothing good is happening over here
no way although San Diego has had it in
the lowest numbers that's interested
because they opened up yeah really but I
also saw on Twitter that they were
begging to be shut down because
everywhere surrounding San Diego is
closing and then they didn't want people
to flock to San Diego I mean here's the
thing it's like what's the thing here it
is what do we do we don't know you know
what I think New Zealand's doing a great
job can we just borrow whoever is in
charge of New Zealand don't know what to
do in other news Justine and I are
thinking about starting an eSports
organization so we've decided we decided
today listen today I used to actually be
really good at call of duty until what I
no no like a long like I'm just
replaying her or duo's and gave me exact
okay so I haven't played much I work so
well Call of Duty first came out I love
playing free-for-all like I live for
free-for-all I play that and I play a
lot of team deathmatch so just those
types of games were always my favorite
and then should I stopped playing for
sure and then Animal Crossing came out
really just a low-low talent game for
Animal Crossing you know like you just
walk not lootellan are you saying
piggyback don't touch me don't touch me
the more you play like you're not gonna
get better at it just water kicking back
getting better at terraforming I know
right where to stick my shotgun I guess
so but like is it skill based I mean I
love okay sometimes I can't catch those
silly fish so I think there's different
levels I will say there are some
incredibly designed islands that I can
never in a million years or a million
hours get my island to look that cold
well I agree my ilex like trash I know
what you're saying so where am I going
with this
like Call of Duty is one of those things
I mean maybe you're born amazing with it
but the more you play like the better
you get you know you're getting
familiarized with the gameplay you're
getting familiarized with the maps
getting loadouts
like leveling up your guns like there's
just so much where you can advance so
for the past three months of quarantine
I have been playing basically every
night with my friends so I've been
playing so much and they keep making
updates to the game and just kind of
like staying up-to-date like what gun do
we need what do we do bubble blah you
know you get it so Justine we played the
other day I was just doing dumb stuff
and asking dumb questions but we
captured this shot of me I was trying to
I was asking Jenny I saw there was a
money bag on the map which that
signifies one of the top earners that we
want to take down so that we can get
their money anyway I was jumping to see
if I could see him so I was jumping up
and down somebody else was behind me and
they were like what is this fool doing
snipes me right little head like popping
up but I was just telling Jenna on the
stream I'm like man I'm doing dumb stuff
over here and then Oh done headshot boom
but they caught it on the kill cam you
could see me hopping like a fascinating
I mean so our eSports organization I
don't know if you know will be playing
professionally I think you know if
somebody wants to sponsor the eSports
team technically that would be more
professionals because isn't that how you
determine if you're professional if
you're making money doing something
Twitter has me categorized as a
professional Call of Duty player my KD
was positive I think to be able to like
play in a tournament like you should
have like above a 3 KD I'm not I can't
see that we're not are we gonna catch a
good attitude let me play we can make
our own tournament we can do whatever we
want and listen I just want to say you
can do whatever you want you can do
whatever you want within reason within
reason okay yeah but I'm saying like if
you have like a cool idea I might take
some work
no sexy fell off Oh
do whatever you you can if it's legal
speaking of legal fun trying to find a
segue into something else that I thought
about talking oh okay this is actually
super exciting okay okay okay okay
Walmart they are turning a hundred and
sixty of their parking lots into
drive-in movie theaters Wow isn't it
crazy they'll think of dollars himself
without an excitement it's really really
cool I make a really great idea and
here's the thing is what I love is
companies are trying to shift and figure
out like what to do obviously yes to
make money but how can we how can they
also keep us entertained I mean I don't
I don't know like there has to be new
ways invented to do things so obviously
drive-ins are not a new technology but
it's like crazy how many of them have
been shut down because people like we're
not doing this we're gonna go to the
movie theaters and now it's like we
don't wanna go to the movie theaters but
we still want that experience hello
welcome to this old technology that is
being reinvented in Walmart parking lots
and also what this is really cool like I
mean I've done a bunch of projects with
Walmart and they've always been really
fun to work with but they're also doing
this they are launching a virtual summer
camp in addition to the drive-in movie
theaters as well to help families make
the most out of summer so there's a
bunch of different celebrity and expert
lead camp sessions so they're gonna roll
out across the summer so there's the
great family challenge so you have
family bonding activities drew Barrymore
oh I love her she's taking campers
through a makeup tutorial LeBron James
is leading participants through mental
and physical activities this is really
do something we can teach we can teach
people how to podcast well hmm we how
about how to make a vlog I'm not even
doing that for a while oh my gosh oh
okay let me call Walmart hello it's just
seen hi yes we've got an idea yes so we
want to teach something in your virtual
summer camp we're gonna teach vlogging
it's important there's nobody on the
phone I don't think so because you don't
send an email yes this is so cool the
holiday weekend of the week
July 4th today we shouldn't do anything
let's not do anything you should have
made a bacon cooking video yeah we
anyway you know I'm speaking of cooking
where's our posts mates just ordered it
I'm Emily I understand I can take a look
and see what's happening order has been
updated they're preparing order what is
your favorite piece of technology right
now my iPhone you can do anything and
everything with this iPhone like if I if
every piece of my technology has would
go away I could still continue doing
what I'm doing with this it's very true
you can make a podcast you can make
vlogs I can edit on here how we're gonna
do all that while wirelessly charging oh
my god she got me oh she got oh oh she
got me wait wait which one was one you
sure yeah is it more like for me okay
but I'm bummed for me womp womp for you
if there aren't any ports on the iPhone
they could have the smart connector like
on the iPad so do like 3rd cases that
they have now with like the battery
cases they would have a smart connector
port case but even Mophie has a bunch of
those wireless charging cases so yeah I
can still have the wireless charging
cases but also the smart connector on
the iPad that can also do pass-through
charging so there's a lot of different
options I think that they can true kind
of seemingly go through but I'm not sure
how the data speeds would be when you're
transferring through like magnetic yeah
that is true so well so there's a lot of
you think about there's so much I feel
like I'm getting a little overwhelmed
but what I'm saying is by me being a
part of the problem like constantly
reviewing new tech I agree okay I've
only used 155 machines I want to answer
my question
oh are you yes you're part of the
problem well yes and no because here's
the thing people I feel like rely on
these reviews like if I'm gonna buy
something I go i watch a review I find
people I can trust
I want to learn about it how many times
have you bought something and you're
like this is terrible I wasted my money
that is true reviewing this like
reviewing these things gives people they
can make you know they can make informed
decisions on that same sense there
hasn't been many times I've bought
something that I didn't like because I
have watched
who's actually so there you go there's
that's actually okay Jenna has made a
good point so that's what I'm here for
it so I'm getting paid the big bucks
we are pissed we can you don't have any
podcast sponsors are not making any
money I'm yeah but yeah think about it
think about it yeah I'm thinking about
it remember when you bought that DJ set
you haven't used so that's we could be
using that right now actually oh we
could be yep
we might actually we can oh my goodness
this is great you know we should do we
should do a live stream where we learn
how to make music okay I herand arty
Ariella party I love already as well
maybe who want to do a live stream we do
a squad stream I have he does a lot of
stuff from his surface book as well
really mm-hmm
I have Ableton well shoot I bought it I
bought the licence I believe her to
learn how to make music might as well
we've got podcasts for your streaming
again we're gaming I started drawing I
was trying to draw us a logo for same
brain Chanukah
well I wrote small brain first I was
like oh my iPad using procreate I was
like oh my god I start writing I was
like so I was like oh my god this is not
even the right for you name but I can't
I can't I can't I can't
that's my favorite thing I don't know if
I told you guys this but when I was
setting up the anchor username because
it was originally iJustine because I had
it from a long time ago so I had to
change it to same brain it autocorrected
to lay my brain and I was I didn't even
realize it and I hit save and published
so the RSS feed originally said
lamebrain
what if okay what if our logo is it says
small crossed out and then same brain I
mean that's we don't have a logo we
don't but it's okay I mean I will say I
did go to Fiverr to get one made so
we're I'm still waiting to my revision
we'll see how that goes did you send a
revision no I think I'm gonna keep
looking at we're gonna keep looking I
think we go to Twitter you think yeah a
lot of great stuff comes out of Twitter
a lot
trash comes out yeah you know what one
of my favorite life things I've ever
heard this was I think relating to
dating but I guess it could be real life
it was there's a lot of fish in the
ocean there's a lot there's efficiency a
lot of fish in the sea but there's also
a lot of trash oh I laugh every time I
think about it there was I think got the
trash in the ocean that's a serious
problem it is a serious problem
you know referring back to like dating
and just like people and trash anyway
Bill burr said this on his podcast he
said I mean I'm sure or someone else's
at this but I heard him say not too long
ago that everything you've touched is
somewhere like your trash is somewhere
like something you simply think about
that that's like a really crazy
have you seen Walde recently Wally yeah
no like recently the movie no okay this
was a good chat of you yeah I was
watching it but it was like on and I was
also all my phone's it was just oh
what's the point of that conversation
that we're having now because I miss it
but there was a lot of trash okay it's a
bad story anyway probably cut the last
15 minutes those podcasts out you is
that the mouse for the surface it is oh
my gosh did you need that yeah I was
looking for that let's forget you I see
you found it all right
you me tell you what just eaten hmm I
have nothing else to say really no I'm
thinking a second let's see if just
maybe Elsinore list that we went oh
there is some stuff I want to talk about
there's been rumors of a new mini LED
iPad and Mac Book Pro mmm
we love a good rumor well it's rumored
but I feel like it's actually probably
gonna happen planning to release a
high-end twelve point nine inch iPad pro
with a mini LED display and 5g and 2021
soon it looks like they were originally
planning to launch it in the fall of
2020 but I mean we don't like things
happening yeah I mean do you think it's
also gonna affect like the iPhone with
like production and packaging and all of
that type of things a lot of people have
been saying that so there's a really
good chance that the iPhone
mutilate this year how but this phone is
still so good so so new I haven't even
used half of the storage well I have
used all the storage and I'm so sad
we're not a camera camp this year last
year Jenna I did an event with Sony was
called camera camp we had honestly the
best time ever she was in Montana around
but like I guess September it was always
a the I don't was was out I was in say
was the day that our niece was also born
yes so two things were born that night
three things the iPhone our camera camp
and Brees baby Santa Monica's calling me
do you think that they is it your car
once you take that call yeah just maybe
they might have a things have you heard
a voice mail your just fool it's not yes
it is yeah 100% because I called you the
other day from your call box and it said
it was full and I couldn't leave you
message hello oh my god was harsh before
hook closed that was John with a Land
Rover Santa Monica yeah I know my car is
gonna be done at 4 o'clock today they
told me originally it was gonna be
tomorrow they close at 5:00 so you
better make sure you got it there was a
recall here's the thing about cars
sometimes those recalls actually had one
as well if you're in your car right now
you should do yourself a you know a good
solid do yourself a solid and look if
there's a recall on your car because my
car is only you're an apple and every
time I turn the car off I would get out
and it sounded like it was gonna explode
so you shouldn't check while you're
driving though if there's a no-no just
make a mental note and I was like you
know what I'm just gonna take this in
its Elise I would don't want to worry
about this and he was like yeah there's
a recall on your cooling cool cool good
something okay well you tell me no
pattern I'm like like just about why go
honestly is like just just take my money
fix it and call me when it's done
wait they're taking your money yeah oh I
also well not for the recall but they're
also supposed to bring your car in every
year for a checkup
or okay so it's a year or ten thousand
miles I'm a year and
half at 7,000 miles so I made a judgment
call and said I think this is what I'm
gonna bring my car in you know not in a
year and not ten thousand so they
charged you for the recall or no no not
for the recall fixing Bhattacharjee four
hundred dollars for a checkup why I
don't know how to talk let me have a
talk like I probably needed an oil
change but I don't think an oil change
should cost $400 what did they check
exactly because if you want me to check
your car for $400 I will take a check at
it I'll take a look I think a real
thorough look I don't know I think I got
ripped off honestly but I remember
taking it there one time and it was like
$700 what did they do
I think I need to get a new car did they
what did they do to your car I don't
know Justine I'll have to check since it
is at least I want them to know that I'm
taking care of it that's a good thing I
gave my last car back that was Elise I
still had to pay like $1,600 so like
temperatures like this is 8,000 it's a
whole thing I really say earth could
have they were like tip temperature
temperature what's our next car gonna be
is it gonna be the truck cyber truck my
lease is up when that's coming out I
keep forgetting that it's called a cyber
truck cuz that's like like it's called a
cyber truck it's called wild incredible
do you think that your next car is gonna
be all-electric I think so I mean no I
don't think so I know so because
honestly when we did when I had that
Jaguar fur I was a few months ago Jaguar
ipace it was amazing it was so so great
like I absolutely loved it and it was
electric it wasn't it didn't drive
itself or anything like that but it
still was absolutely amazing I love it
it's really bad it was just the fact
that there's so many more charging ports
now and like it's so much more
accessible and I really haven't been
driving much now since really going
anywhere but also I love the
over-the-air updates I know they can
like Tesla can literally make your car
faster we talked about this with an
update and I'm just I don't know my
lease is up in like a year and a half
I'm excited to see what cars are gonna
be out and well I'm gonna be pushing
that whip and I won't have to get her
oil change you don't have a Frank
[Laughter]
franck right what a funny red truck
don't know cuz it's like you don't have
an engine you got a Franck it's true I'm
gonna put stuff in cups of water in the
Frog hop yeah I'll put my backpack in
your fro did I leave something in your
Franck
can I see in your frog can you go check
your front good you have in your friend
are my french fries in your fries you're
not sure oh my god did we hit an hour
yet do you think we did it oh my shoes
are in the front you guys were trying so
hard to make it to an hour are you still
there are you are you see last minutes
in the front and the animal okay so so I
found some crystals
oh no absolutely not we're gonna leave
us out of this out of this segment well
we have we have we're at the end of the
segment now we need a few more minutes
to make it to an hour so I thought I
found some really cool crystals that I
bought at a crystal shop I don't know
what they are I think we actually bought
these when we were in we were shooting
the iPhone one video wash the iPhone 11
everything Todd you remember that Tyler
well we I think I went into a gem shop
in Hatton Beach in Manhattan Beach
Malibu was that no it wasn't in Hatton
Beach wait was it on the pier or was it
at Manhattan Beach think this was in a
back alley that we went into a gem shop
and I bought these I thought they're
really pretty ones like a heart and um
and I looked up what they were they are
I think it's a moonstone I can't get on
board with it I understand it like the
energy but they're really pretty so just
like do I want rocks around me let's see
what these do okay the moonstone is good
for clearing the mind and senses it aids
in lucid dreaming and calm sleep do you
Lex
negativity and eases emotional trauma
well I'm still here so it's not
deflecting enough wait wait what oh I
was gonna go okay keep talking keep
talking about your stones um they're
really shiny this one is shaped as a
heart it's quite beautiful
look at it I just think they're pretty I
mean I don't know I mean I don't know a
lot about gem you have an infrared Matt
how's that going for you it's really
great for that time of the month oh when
I lay on it Oh
the infrared spa I saw also opened up
again which is kind of concerning I'm
not leaving the house I don't really
ever want to leave the house again I'm
now touching the gems to seeing it I
feel cleanse me smooth rocks look I feel
like pebbles of the water earth water
her thank you guys so much for watching
wait no listening oh my god I forgot
what we're doing it's a podcast you're
listening you might be watching we also
have a video version that may
potentially be somewhere we don't know
the future of the podcast is in I guess
everyone's hands really pretty crazy
guys enjoying it if you are make sure
you guys leave us a nice rating and
you're not keep it to yourself to get
your song taking feedback cuz this is
still pretty new but we just want to say
thank you for being so supportive of
everything and all of our journeys in
our podcast also thank you for the
feedback because I know we told you guys
to tweet us and a bunch of you have
tweeted us and we are working on getting
a whole new set up so I'm very excited
to show you guys that hopefully in our
next episode so I guess we will see you
guys soon and that's it this is Justine
signing off and this is Jenna I'm also
going goodbye
[Music]